ja ich freue mich außerordentlich heute
als Interviewpartner Professor Vittorio
Hösle dabei zu haben Herr Hösle ist
Professor unter anderem auch für
Philosophie an der University of N Dame
in Indiana in den USA und Herr Professor
Hösle hat im Jahr 1991 ein Buch
geschrieben mit dem Titel Philosophie
der ökologischen Krise das wird immer
noch sehr viel behandelt zitiert es ist
auch übersetzt worden in verschiedene
Sprachen und mich würde als erstes Inter
wie sie ihr Verhältnis zu Hans Jonas
beschreiben würden der ja auch ein Buch
geschrieben hat das Prinzip
Verantwortung es es veröffenticht worden
im Jahr
1979 wie würden sie ihren naturethischen
Ansatz von seinem
abgrenzen ja also zunächst einmal möchte
ich sagen wie sehr ich von Jonas
beeinflusst bin das Buch ist ja auch
Hans Jonas
gewidmet ich bin Jonas 1986 erstmals
begegnet ich war damals vising Assisten
Professor an der New School social
research an am philosophy Department wo
ja hansjonas mit Hanna Arend unter
anderem Professor gewesen war und dass
ich dann dort eine Professur auf
Lebenszeit eine erhalten habe war eben
auch dem Einsatz hansonas zu verdanken
er kam zu meinem Vortrag er hat mich zu
sich nach Hause eingeladen ich habe ihn
dafür das erenische Staatsfernsehen
interviewt wir waren also im engen
geistigen Austausch und ich fühle mich
außerordentlich ihm verbunden ich muss
allerdings sagen dass ich wie ügens er
selber auch
für sein Hauptwerk nicht das Prinzip
Verantwortung halte sondern das phommen
of life in der deutschen Fassung heißt
das Buch Organismus und Freiheit das
scheint mir sozusagen die umfassendste
Grundlage der Philosophie Hans Jonas zu
bieten und ich lege immer großen Wert
darauf wenn man von Hans mich jemand
fragt was soll ich von Hans Jonas lesen
dass man zuerst mit dem phänomenon of
life beginnt und dann erst das Prinzip
Verantwortung liest denn viele der
Passagen im Prinzip Verantwortung
eben zur telelogie der Natur geben viel
besseren Sinn wenn man vertraut ist mit
dem früheren Werke
und was ist sich was ist der Unterschied
zwischen unseren Ansätzen also ich
möchte zal beginnen mit dem worin wir
uns einig sind wir sind un zweifels ohne
darin einig dass eine der größten
Herausforderung der Menschheit seit der
bakonischen Revolution darin besteht die
massive Umwandlung der Natur die wir aus
verständlichen Gründen zur Behebung
schlimmer menschlicher not in die Wege
geleitet haben so begrenzen dass
menschliches Leben und nicht nur
menschliches Leben sondern eben auch das
Überleben anderen Arten von Pflanzen und
Tieren äh auf unbegrenzte Weise auf
unbegrenzte Zeit auf hoher auf hohem
Niveau möglich bleibt und es ist leider
nicht garantiert dass wir bewegen uns ja
mit großen Schritten auf eine
Katastrophe zu es ist gut möglich dass
am Ende dieses Jahrhunderts die Erde in
vielen Teilen nicht mehr bewohnbar sein
wird und
dies ist ein ernstes Problem das
angegangen werden muss und Jonas hat den
Mut gehabt als einer der ersten war
nicht der erste eines der ersten Bücher
ist von pasmore John pasmore dem
australischen Philosophen responsibility
also über Verantwortung für zukünftige
Generationen äh äh und Bezug auf Natur
nachzudenken aber jonas hat eben eine
umfassende Theorie vorgelegt die unter
anderem deswegen faszinierend ist weil
er sozusagen
den den die
Mentalität freigelegt hat die dem
Projekt der Beherrschung der Natur
zugrunde legt also das was er das
bakonische Ideal nennt und darin folgte
natürlich seinem Lehrer Martin heideger
denn er versucht soz sagen bestimmte
geschichtsphilosophische
Weichenstellungen intellektueller Art in
Verbindung zu bringen mit dem Projekt
der Moderne und seiner
naturzerstörerischen Dimension
gleichzeitig hat Jonas etwas was
heiliger völlig fehlt er hat eine sehr
starke ethische Bindung heidigers
Philosophie ist eine amoralische
Philosophie ich fürchte heideg als
Mensch war auch ein ziemlich
unmoralischer Mensch Hans Jonas dagegen
hält an einem kategorischen Imper die
fest ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass
H Jonas kan viel meher steht als oft
dargestellt wird ähm äh und selbst in
der konkreten Bezugnahme auf die Natur
ist ja sein Prinzip zunächst einmal ein
Prinzip dass ich als gemäßigten
anthropozentrismus ausgesprochen habe
also Jonas geht davon aus dass unsere
Pflicht die Erde in einem bestimmten
Zustande unseren Nachfahren zu
hinterlassen primär zu tun hat mit un
mit den Pflichten unseren Nachkommen
gegenüber allerdings und er hat gar
keinen Zweifel dass von allen Wesen
allen Lebewesen der Mensch den höchsten
intrinsischen Wert hat in dem Buch das
Prinzip Verantwortung lässt er die Frage
weitgehend offen ob die Menschen das
einzige Lebewesen mit intrinsischen wert
sind oder ob wir intrinsischen Wert also
unabhängig von dem Nutzen für den
Menschen auch anderen m zuschreiben
können aber wenn man eben Organismus und
Freiheit kennt ist es ziemlich klar dass
Hans Jonas stark in diese Richtung neigt
allerdings eben mit einer klaren
Hierarchisierung er vertritt die alte
Skala nature das verschiedene Formen des
Lebens verschiedenen Wert haben und die
menschliche Daseinsform ist die höchste
gleichzeitig beruht ja die Originalität
des Buches Phenomen auf life darin dass
Hans Jonas im Grunde den Seinsbegriff
heidigas in sein und Zeit generalisiert
h Jonas kam zu dem Ergebnis dass die
Grundstruktur der Sorge die den Menschen
als ähnliches Vernunftwesen kennzeichnet
in einer umfassenderen Struktur
begründet ist die alle Organismen aus
auszeichnet nämlich die Tatsache dass
Organismen Nahrung brauchen ihre Form ih
sehr komplexe Form nur erhalten können
indem sie sich neue Materie aneignen sie
sind auf Stoffwechsel angewiesen und
diese Grundstruktur des organischen äh
teilt der Mensch auch wenn er ihr dann
eben eine besondere Wendung
eine viel komplexere Form der Erfüllung
gibt
und all das fand ich außordentlich
faszinierend äh was ich von Jonas
gelernt habe sind also drei Dinge
erstens dass wir eine Philosophie der
Biologie brauchen um die geistnatur des
Menschen in der Biologie stärker zu
fundieren als etwa die tansianische
Tradition tut zweitens brauchen wir mit
Kant ein kategorisches Prinzip wir
können nicht wie einige naturpantheisten
den Menschen ganzen der Natur aufgehen
lassen sondern wir müssen anerkennen
dass der Mensch eine Sonderstellung
innerhalb der Natur hat einerseits weil
der Mensch allein moralische Subjekt
sein kann andererseits aber gerade
deswegen weil er allein moralisches
Subjekt sein kann ein einen moralischen
Status hat der besonders wertvoll ist
und drittens habe ich von J was gelernt
dass man versuchen muss
äh den äh die die ökologische Krise in
eine umfassende Theorie der Veränderung
unserer Vorstellungen dessen was Natur
ist und was die Aufgabe des Menschen den
innerhalb der Natur ist einzurücken wo
unterscheide ich mich von Jonas ich
glaube in verschiedenen Punkten der
erste Punkt ist dass ich z.B glaube ich
ausführlicher als er äh in dem zweiten
Kapitel meines Buches die Philosophie vi
der ökologischen Krise
die
Differenzierung Differenzierungen
zwischen dem antiken und dem modernen
wissenschafts Begriff ähm betreibe Jonas
geht zw von der radikalen
Andersartigkeit der Moderne aus aber
unterschätzt meinesachtens das ist ja
schon dass die wissenschaftliche
Revolution des 17 jahrhunderts die
zweite Wissenschaft die Revolution der
Menschheit war die erste erfolgt im 5ün
vier vorchristlichen Jahrhundert und
mich interessiert sehr warum diese
wissenschaftliche Revolution ähm eben
anders gelaufen ist als die spätere und
die Unterscheidung der fünf
naturbegriffe von den archaischen
Kulturen zum postkartesianischen
Naturbegriff halte ich weiterhin für
eine der interessantesten Teile dieses
zweiten Kapitels die im dritten Kapitel
in der Ethik bin ich stark von Jonas
beeinflusst ich bin affirmativer als er
was den intrinsischen werd in
natürlicher Gebilde angeht äh auch wenn
also Organ von Organismen außerhalb des
Menschen angeht auch wenn ich wie eher
dem Menschen eine Sonderstellung
innerhalb des organischen und daher
einen höheren intrinsischen Wert zu
spreche aber wo ich mich sehr stark von
ih unterscheide ist das vierte Kapitel
das vierte Kapitel versucht ja äh die
Ethik der Ökonomie angesichts der
Umweltkrise zu entwickeln und Jonas
hatte ja im Prinzip Verantwortung was
damals bei vielen Horror auslöste etwa
bei Karl Popper sich ja der Hoffnung
hingegeben dass die Planwirtschaft der
Sowjetunion das Problem äh leichter
lösen könne als der Markt ich bin sehr
skeptisch gegenüber jeder Planwirtschaft
habe sicher eine stärkeren er glauben an
Marktmechanismen als Hans Jonas und die
wirtschaftspolitische Position von der
ich immer geprägt war im Grunde seit
meiner Jugend weil der Vater äh der der
Cousin meines Vaters dr Reinhold feit
war der Direktor des Walter euken
Instituts in Freiburg und Walter euken
war ja der Begründer des deutschen
Ordoliberalismus ich erinnere mich noch
genau wie edit euken die Witwe von
Walter euken uns in Regensburg besuchte
als ich etwa 10 Jahre alt war und ich
erinere mich an das intelligente Gesicht
dieser Frau die Russin war und der
odoliberalismus hat mir immer stark
eingeleuchtet auf der einen Seite sind
Märkte der effizienteste Mechanismus um
eine all um ein Gleichgewicht zwischen
äh Angebot und Nachfrage zu erreichen
und eben
allokationsrationalität zu erhöhen
andererseits müssen die
Rahmenbedingungen des Marktes von einem
Staat gesetzt werden dessen Beamte nicht
der Logik des Marktes untergeordnet sind
und so plädiere ich ja sehr stark in
diesem vierten Kapitel die Rationalität
des Marktes Z Gunsten der
umweltbewahrung wirken zu lassen durch
ein System von Umweltsteuern ähm und äh
später habe ich eben ausführlicher über
umweltzölle gesprochen wohl ich ja im
Prinzip an den Freihandel glaube aber
eben nur wenn er so äh eingerichtet wird
dass die Transportkosten den realen
Preisen äh entsprechen und wenn einige
Staaten sich dem entziehen und dadch äh
Begünstigungen auf dem Weltmarkt
erlangen darf man sich dagegen mit
umweltzöllen wehren äh und in dieser
Verteidigung sozusagen der möglichen
Rationalität des Marktes sage nicht dass
S äh von Natur aus so ist sondern nur
innerhalb eines Ordoliberalen Rahmen in
der die Ordnung selber von moralischen
Prinzipien geleitet ist weich ich stark
von hansjonas ab ebenso glaube ich auch
in den politischen Kapitel jonas hat ja
eine ganz großartige Frage gestellt im
Prinzip Verantwortung die von den
politischen Philosophen vorhin kaum
gestellt worden war nämlich wer vertritt
eigentlich die kommenden
Generationen gleichzeitig hat aber eher
eine gewisse skeps ist gegenüber
demokratischen Institutionen während
mein Versuch schon in der Philosophie
der ökologischen Krise und darauf viel
aufgearbeiteten besser begründeten und
detaillierteren Niveau in Moral und
Politik darin besteht sich Institutionen
rechtlicher und politischer Natur auszud
denken die es wahrscheinlicher machen
dass die großen Verlierer der beiden
modernen hauptinstitutionen des Marktes
und der Demokratie nämlich die kommende
Generation die keine Kaufkraft und kein
Stimmrecht haben stärker berücksichtigt
werden eben einerseits durch
Umweltsteuern die im Grunde nur ein
Ausdruck sind der Nachfrage kommender
Generation wäre die auf dem Markt
präsent würden natürlich die Preise für
knappe Güter sofort nach oben gehen
andererseits aber dass Ihre Bedürfnisse
durch ein eigenes Staatsorgan
berücksichtigt werden auch wenn sie
selber diese Vertreter noch nicht wählen
können das sind glaube ich die
entscheidenden Unterschiede also in in
derusagen der in der in der Größen
Einordnung in in der großflächigen
Einordnung äh der Entwicklung würde ich
sagen ich stehe im klassischen
Liberalismus viel näher
als Hans Jonas weil ich die Erfahrungen
mit antiliberalen Systemen 20
Jahrhunderts waren mus es freundlich zu
sagen eher ernüchternd äh obwohl ich mit
Jonas der festen Überzeugung bin dass
ohne massive Veränderung in den
Rahmenbedingungen von Markt und
Demokratie das Böse Ende auf die das
bakonische Projekt hinausläuft
unvermeidlich ist ja vielen Dank das ist
sehr erhellend ihr Kontrast zu Hans
Jonas jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage die
eher metaphysisch ontologische Art ist
sie fundieren ja auch ihre naturthik
durch eine Ontologie oder einen
objektiven Idealismus könnten Sie
vielleicht ganz kurz unseren
zuschauerinen und zuschauernen erklären
wie sie den Objektiven Idealismus ihre
Position auf die naturethik anwenden h
also auch da besteht ein gewisser
Unterschied zu Hans Jonas Hans Jonas hat
ja sehr stark die Wendung von hussal zu
heidiger mitgemacht
er erzählt das ja auch sehr schön in
seiner Autobiografie die ich für ein der
interessantesten philosophischen
Autobiografien halte meine eine meiner
lieblingspassagen die sich erst im
Anhang in einem Anhang
zu dem Buch findet dass ja nicht von
Jonas selber veröffentlicht wurde
sondern erst postum herauskam aufgrund
von tonbaddiktaten da erzählt der
folgende Anekdote um die Weltfremdheit
hussals klar zumachen die eben der
Generation die im Ersten Weltkrieg
bewusst geworden war irgendwie sauer
aufstieß ein Student kam von Berlin
zurück und
erzählte glaube be ein Abendessen mit
Professor hussal er habe in Berlin da
sei in Berlin gewesen und da habe er
Prostituierte auf der Straße gesehen
darauf sagte hussal das kann nicht sein
nein Professor hussal das sind wirklich
Prostituierte gewesen nein sagte hussal
Prostituierte gibt es in Paris aber
nicht in der Stadt von Hegel und
Schleiermacher und das ist eine Form von
Weltfremdheit die sagen wir mal äh für
diese junge Generation lächerlich wirkte
und
eidagegen schien mit seinem Begriff des
Daseins äh dass sozusagen die
menschliche Existenz in die in der
Geschichte und den Kämpfen der
Geschichte erdete einfach viel näher an
der Wahrheit als die transzendentale
epocheusal und Jonas hat deswegen
letztlich zwar eine komplexe Theorie der
Sonderstellung des Geistes im Verhältnis
zur Natur aber er hat keine eigene
Sphäre des
idealen wähend diese natürlich bei
hussal von den logischen Untersuchungen
an eine unglaubliche Rolle spielt und
ich stehe in dem Sinne hussal viel näher
als heidiger und Jonas ich gehe davon
aus dass ist eine eigene Ideale Sphäre
gibt die Natur vorausgeht und in der
auch sozusagen moralische Prinzipien
angesiedelt sind äh und meine Position
in der Metaethik ist dass eben
wir annehmen müssen dass eine eigene
Ideale Sphäre des Sollens gibt dass aber
diese Sphäre des Sollens sozusagen sich
auswirkt auf die Struktur der realen
Welt auch die Struktur der Natur Natur
muss so strukturiert sein dass in ihr
mit intrinsischen Werte sich entfalten
und eben das auch die besondere
Existenzweise des Organismus Homo
sapiens darin ihren Grund hat dass wir
z.B durch die Erfahrung unserer
Endlichkeit in ganz anderer Weise vor
der Frage stellen vor der Frage stehen
wie wir
uns angesichts unserer Sterblichkeit in
einem begrenzten
Zeitraum um unsere icht en bemühen einer
meiner Lieblingstexte von honas ist ja
eine seiner letzten Texte diese
großartige Rede und the burden blessing
of mortality Last und Segen der
Sterblichkeit übrigens eine Rede die
meines Erachtens von Thomas
Manz entsprechend im Aufsatz aus den
50er Jahren beeinflusst ist Hans Jonas
phenomenon of life verdankt sehr sehr
viel der Philosophie der Biologie die
Thomas Mann im Zauberberg entwickelt
jonas hat das übrigens in seiner
Autobiografie auch anerkannt äh und so
sehe ich also einerseits mit Jonas und
heideger darin einig bin dass das
Vernunftwesen Mensch
in
dieser in einem Organismus angesiedelt
ist so sehr meine ich dass das
neematische Objekt der Ethik der
Gegenstand der Ethik ist ein Prinzip das
einer idealen Ordnung und Welt angehört
und das ist ein großer Teil dessen was
ich als objektiven Idealismus annehme
und gleichzeitig eben obwohl die reale
Welt von dieser idealen Welt
Unterschieden ist gehe ich erstens davon
aus dass sie durchlässig ist für die
Entfaltung von Werten und dass
andererseits die Endlichkeit die dem
Menschen zukommt ind dem er Teil dieser
Welt ist letztlich auch einen
moralischen Sinn hat ja vielen Dank das
führt mich zur nächsten Frage
zum Begriff des anthropozehs der ja erst
im Jahr 2000 geprägt wurde durch den
atmosphä Chemiker Paul grutzen der auch
Nobelpreis bekommen hat für seine
Forschung im Kontext des Ozonlochs sie
haben in ihrer Schrift von 191 natürlich
den Begriff noch nicht verwendet wie
würden Sie sich jetzt aus der heutigen s
zum Begriff und Phänomen des
anthropozens Verhalten halten Sie den
Begriff für sinnvoll für analytisch
hilfreich wie verhalten Sie sich dazu ja
ich halte auf jeden Fall für sinn
voll denn es ist ohne Zweifel so dass
seit der Industrialisierung neben
besonderem Maße seit im 20 jahrhundert
die Veränderungen die menschliches
Verhalten in der Atmosphäre aber in der
ganzen Biosphäre unseres Planeten
angerichtet hat durchaus vergleichbar
sind denen die in früheren Zeiten
katastrophale Ereignisse wie ein
asteroideninschlag
der Dinosaurier zum Aussterben brachte
verursacht hat also ich halte es ohne
Zweifel richtig zu sagen richtig zu
sagen hier passiert etwas radikal neues
also viele Biologen gehen ja davon aus
dass wir eine Art seches Massen
Aussterben von tierischen und
pflanzlichen Arten erleben und dieses
Aussterben ist zu guten Teil durch
unsere Spezies durch den Menschen
bedingt gleichzeitig möchte ich eben
aber auch ein Punkt Wiederholen der
sicher pa küum vollkommen klar war war
vielleicht nicht jedem der von
anthropozen spricht der Mensch kann der
Natur sehr großen Schaden anrichten
Natur ist damit gemeint der Biosphäre
aber die Natur sitzt natürlich am Hebbel
denn der Mensch kann nur innerhalb der
Natur überleben und das heißt wenn der
anthropoen wenn das anthropoen wirklich
auf einen Zusammenbruch der Bio großer
Teile der Biosphäre hinauslaufen wird
dann wird der Mensch das nicht überleben
das heißt das anthropoen wird eine sehr
kurze Epoche
sein auch wenn dann die Natur auch nach
dem Aussterben des Menschen
wahrscheinlich sehr lange brauchen wird
um sich wieder zu erholen ja vielen Dank
noch eine abschließende Frage die auch
ein bisschen die Zukunft blickt was muss
in ihren Augen die Politik tun aber auch
das Individuum tun um die Gefahren die
jetzt mit unserer Lebensweise ein
herergehen auch die Gefahren des
anthropoäns möglichst noch zu vermeiden
glauben Sie es geht noch oder ist es
schon zu spät also die Frage ist sehr
schwer zu beantworten und ich als
Philosoph bin natürlich nicht kompetent
zu sagen
ab welchem
Temperaturanstieg menschliches Leben
geringe Chancen hat wie groß die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass wir diesen
temperaturstieg innerhalb W Zeitraumes
haben da müssen sie Klimatologen fragen
was ich sagen will ist ich war früher
optimistischer als ich heute bin äh und
äh das Buch 1991 geschrieben S in Moskau
weil ich damals
eben auch an der großen Hoffnung Teil
hatte dass der Zusammenbruch des
kommunistischen Totalitarismus ähm
Russland wieder in die Gemeinschaft der
Liberalen friedensliebenden Nationen
zurückführen würde dieser Enthusiasmus
und dieser Optimismus ist ja leider
verflogen sowohl was die Zukunft Frust
angeht das eine Form des Totalitarismus
mit einer noch hässlicheren
faschistischen ausgetauscht hat als auch
was die Fähigkeit der Menschen angeht
wirklich zu handeln die Probleme sind ja
inzwischen relativ klar begriffen und
nur dumme Ideologen bestreiten
das Ausmaß der von Menschen verursachten
Schäden aber äh es hat sich als
außerordentlich schwierig erwiesen z.B
ein System von wirklich sinnvollen
Umweltsteuern einzuführen wir besteuern
es war schon die CO2 Emission in der
Europäischen Union aber mit lächerlich
niedrigen Beträgen überhaupt nicht das
erreichen das eigentlich erforderlich
wäre und das hat natürlich damit zu tun
dass sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten
Formen der Bequemlichkeit ausgebreitet
haben die ohne Zweifel
der Natur ein enormen Schaden zufügen
und die sich immer weiter ausbreiten
weil nach der Logik des modernen
Egalitarismus alle Menschen daran
teilhaben wollen und wie wir das Bremsen
können ist überhaupt nicht klar
und paradoxerweise hat eben die an sich
sehr vernünftige universalistische
Doktrin was dem einen erlaubt ist muss
allen erlaubt sein dazu geführt dass das
Problem zusammen mit der enormen
Steigerung der Weltbevölkerung
sich entsprechend vergrößert hat und
insofern würde ich lügen wenn ich sagen
würde dass ich aus dass ich sehr
optimistisch bin ich glaube
dass die Menschheit so eingerichtet ist
dass sie häufig schrecklicher
Katastrophen bedarf dann aber häufig
wieder zur Raison kommt die Tatsache
dass die Zeit von
1945 bis Ende des Anfang des 21
jahrhunderts eine insgesamt
weltgeschichtlich gesehen relativ
friedfertige Zeit war hat damit zu tun
dass der Schock der beiden ersten
Weltkriege den Menschen so in die
Knochen gefahren haben dass man für
mehrere Jahrzehnte sich vernünftig
verhielt
aber wie ich in meinem Buch die globalen
fri globale friedkräfte geschrieben habe
ist eben das goldene Vierteljahrhundert
1999 bis 2014 nach dem Zusammenbruch des
der kommunistischen Bedrohung
verschwunden wir bewegen uns auf sehr
schwierige Zeiten hinzu in denen sich
das ökologische Problem verkoppeln wird
mit dem Problem
der internationalen Ordnung insbesondere
falls das überhaupt nicht ausgeschlossen
ist Donald Trump als Präsident ins Weiße
Haus zurücktreten wird wir dürfen uns
also auf sehr schwierige Zeiten im Laufe
des 21 jahrhunderts gefasst machen
lassen Sie mich enden mit einem mit
einer Anekdote
arnenes der große norwegische
umweltphilosoph hat in ist Interview mal
gefragt worden sind sie
Optimist am Ende glaube ich des 20
Jahrhunderts wurde gefragt sind sie
Optimist und er sagte ja für das 22
jahrhundert mm ich erwähnte das neulich
gegenüber einem sehr angesehenen
Kollegen an der University rterdam einem
Politikwissenschaftler der schüttelte
den Kopf und sagte als religiöser Mensch
bin ich auch Optimist aber als
Politikwissenschaftler eher für das 24
jahrhundert die nächsten Jahrhunderte
werden enorme Anpassungsprozesse mit
sich bringen tut leid nicht mit einer
besseren
Botschaft Enden zu können aber der
Weihnachts Geschenk des Philosophen
besteht in intellektueller Redlichkeit
ja ganz herzlichen Dank Herr Hösel für
diese sehr aufschlussreichen Ausführung
die vielleicht dazu beitragen können
dass wir doch noch diese Klimakrise
intellektuell zumindest am besser in den
Griff bekommen